I'M FORREST MACNEIL,
AND AS ALWAYS,
I WILL REVIEW ANY EXPERIENCE
YOU WANT ME TO,
NO MATTER WHAT IT IS.
- YOU READY, FORREST?
- YES, I AM.
- OKAY.
THIS COMES FROM NICK
IN SYOSSET, NEW YORK.
- AHA.
- HEY, FORREST.
SO, ON THE BACK OF THIS BOX
OF PANCAKE MIX,
THEY TELL YOU HOW TO MAKE
15 PANCAKES,
BUT IT DOESN'T TELL YOU
HOW TO MAKE ANY FEWER THAN THAT.
SO HERE'S THE THING--
I LIVE ALONE.
DO THEY EXPECT ME
TO EAT 15 PANCAKES?
WHAT'S IT LIKE
- NO. REALLY?
THAT'S THE, UH--
THAT'S THE PROFOUND
LIFE EXPERIENCE
HE WANTS TO KNOW ABOUT--
EATING 15 PANCAKES?
- THAT'S HIS REQUEST, SO...
- YES, THAT IS...
[clears throat]
THE REQUEST
THAT HAS BEEN MADE.
OKAY, NICK,
I'M GOING TO COVER YOUR REQUEST
IN BUTTER AND SYRUP
AND DIG IN TO TRY TO FIND
SOME IMPORTANT MEANING
IN A GIANT, STEAMING PILE
OF FLAPJACKS.
EATING 15 PANCAKES.
- YUM.
- AHH.
THOUGH THIS TASK
WAS CLEARLY MORE SUITED
TO A FRATERNITY BROTHER
WHO HAD LOST A BET
THAN TO A LIFE REVIEWER,
I PREPARED MY STOMACH
AND MY NERVES
FOR A VERY LARGE BREAKFAST.
THE WORLD RECORD
FOR PANCAKES EATEN
IN ONE SITTING
IS 73 PANCAKES.
THAT IS HELD
BY A RUSSIAN MAN
WHOSE LIFE MUST BE
AN UNENDURABLE HELLSCAPE
OF EXCRUCIATING SADNESS.
PERSONALLY, I DOUBT
I'VE EVER HAD
MORE THAN TWO PANCAKES
IN A MONTH.
- OKAY, FIVE TALL STACKS
OF PANCAKES.
- YES.
- THEY SAY BACK IN THE KITCHEN
IF YOU CAN FINISH IT ALL,
WE'LL PUT YOUR PICTURE
UP ON THE WALL.
- MM, NO, I DON'T THINK SO,
BUT THANK YOU.
MAY I HAVE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF WATER, PLEASE?
- YOU GOT IT.
- ALL RIGHT, GOOD.
THIS CERTAINLY IS
AN UPSETTING NUMBER OF PANCAKES.
HERE WE GO.
[dramatic music]
♪
THEY'RE TASTY...
FOR NOW.
♪
THREE PANCAKES IN,
AND I ALREADY FEEL
THAT I HAVE
GREATLY OVERINDULGED.
I AM FULL OF PANCAKES.
ANY RATIONAL PERSON
FEELING THE WAY I DO NOW
WOULD DEFINITELY STOP.
[chuckles]
♪
THERE'S A VERY LOUD THRUMMING
IN MY EARS.
THE BLOOD FEELS VERY SLOW.
OH, GOD.
I HAVE NOW EATEN
TEN PANCAKES,
AND ON THE BRIGHT SIDE,
I CAN SEE THE LIGHT
AT THE END OF THIS
DISGUSTING TUNNEL, BUT...
IT HAS NOW BEEN 45 MINUTES
SINCE I STARTED EATING,
AND THE PANCAKES
ARE NO LONGER HOT.
THESE AREN'T FOOD.
- YOU'RE GONNA BE FINE, BABY.
- WITH 1 1/2 PANCAKES TO GO,
I HAD HIT A WALL.
MY PRODUCER, GRANT,
MADE THE UNPRECEDENTED MOVE
OF STEPPING OUT
FROM BEHIND THE CAMERAS
TO PROVIDE MUCH-NEEDED
MORAL SUPPORT.
- HEY, YOU KNOW YOU GOT
TO FINISH THESE PANCAKES, RIGHT?
- YEAH.
- YOU DO, MAN.
- MM.
- THIS IS YOUR SHOW.
DON'T BAIL ON IT.
- GO AWAY, PLEASE.
- I'M JUST DOING
WHAT YOU TOLD ME TO DO.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET YOU
BACK DOWN.
REMEMBER?
"EVEN IF I BEG TO STOP,
DON'T LET ME."
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID.
- THIS ONE IS REALLY STUPID.
- DO YOU REMEMBER
WHAT YOU TOLD ME
ABOUT THE GUY
WHO SPENT ALL HIS TIME
GROWING FUNGUS ON A STICK?
AND EVERYBODY TOLD HIM
TO KNOCK IT OFF,
AND HE WAS GONNA,
UNTIL IT TURNED OUT
TO BE PENICILLIN.
- MM-HMM.
- THIS COULD BE
YOUR PENICILLIN, FORREST.
- [sighs]
[suspenseful music]
♪
[laughter,
cheers, and applause]
- YOU DID IT.
YOU DID IT!
[laughing]
OKAY, I'LL TAKE THIS
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
- AS I LEFT THE RESTAURANT,
I SCANNED MY SOUL
FOR SOME GREATER WISDOM
TO SHARE WITH HUMANITY.
[heaving]
[spits]
UGH.
[groaning softly]
YEAH, THERE'S NOT REALLY
A WHOLE LOT MORE
TO SAY ABOUT THAT.
IT WAS EXTREMELY UNPLEASANT
AND SHOULD BE AVOIDED
AT ALL COSTS.
EATING 15 PANCAKES--
HALF A STAR.